cominho preto ou nigela Sativa é uma
especiaria muito interessante traz um
arsenal de propriedades incríveis
previne a diabetes combate infecções
auxilia na digestão estimula o sistema
imune e alivia problemas respiratórios
principais benefícios estudados do
cominho Preto São na melhora da Saúde da
tireoide e no tratamento da diabetes
Olha que interessante um estudo da
revista BMC complementary and
alternative medicine mostrou que o
cominho preto ou nigela ass Sativa foi
foi capaz de diminuir os níveis doss
anticorpos relacionados à tiroidite de
Hashimoto que é uma doença autoimune
outro artigo publicado pelo jornal of
endocrinology and metabolism descobriu
que o óleo de cominho preto conseguiu
regenerar parcial e gradualmente as
células Bet pancreáticas diminuindo os
níveis de glicose no sangue pessoal o
cominho é uma das poucas substâncias
capazes de prevenir o diabetes